you know the old adage is you know just
don't judge a book by its cover it lets
someone really be who they who they are
and you know so it's a it's a it's a
cool thing that we that we that we tell
Cameron voices final descendants
interview was just released by Disney
going back to the first movie it was
very much you know we have labels and we
have designated places for these people
that we have placed labels on and very
quickly learn that once you sort of take
a label off of someone and just let them
sort of thrive in whatever environment
they are in you can see the best come
out of someone the interview which was
shot prior to the 20 year olds untimely
death earlier this month features the
late actor talking about descendants
three and so to be able to you know sort
of tell a story in which we say you know
it doesn't matter where you come from it
doesn't matter who you are we are going
to accept you for who you are that's
when people really start to sort of take
in and surroundings and just kind of go
free you know Disney also released some
behind the scenes footage featuring
voice and his co-stars
voices co-stars also sat down for
interviews with the Disney cameras
rolling and opened up about the final
chapter of the franchise it's going to
be incredibly emotional for for us in
the fans of descendants we've been on
this beautiful ride together for five
years now I think fans are gonna enjoy
most about to send in three the
relationships on-screen because they're
so authentic I see people who are family
at this point I think fans are going to
love the musical numbers because I think
we've just built up to this I really do
ét caught up with the cast in May where
they reflected on saying goodbye to
their descendants characters how was it
onset knowing that I mean were you guys
emotional it was it definitely heightens
everything tied into every single day
for us every day was goober emotional
and just every thing became more special
because we knew it was the end
especially the last few days for the
four of us because you know it all
started with the four of us and have
changed our live lives you just kind of
thought it was very sad I'm really
really happy with what Disney allowed us
to do and you know the emotion that they
allowed us to portray and yeah it's my
favorite of the three films for sure